it all started with a panicked phone
call a local landlady who owned a
downtown tenement building had called
the police in hysterics something
horrifying had happened to one of her
tenants she couldn't possibly explain
the one detail she was able to
articulate was that his room looked like
a rain forest a police response team was
on the case in no time they drove down
to the tenement building met the crying
landlady out the door and found their
way to the room that caused all this
confusion when they'd opened the door
they saw with horror that she was right
trees plants fungi and even insects and
animals were all over the room it was
teeming with life the flora and fauna in
this room didn't look like anything else
on earth and given the anomalous nature
of what had happened here it's extremely
possible they were right the tenant a
university professor who'd recently gone
on an anthropological expedition to the
amazon rainforest was nowhere to be seen
but one of the officers spotted a grim
clue for what may have happened to him a
large colony of anomalous mold was
quickly growing on the far wall the
officer swore was a trick of the mind at
first but he was wrong a human skull was
sinking into the tissue of the mold and
to make matters worse whipping tendrils
began to slither from the empty eye
sockets reaching for the new meat
thankfully for everyone who is still
alive at this point the scp foundation
swooped in and took over the situation
with the help of a mobile task force and
some containment specialists the
landlady the cops and the other
residents of the building were given
amnestics and relocated the building was
purchased by the foundation and
condemned while they searched the
anomalous room for the source of this
unchecked biological growth and they
found their answer in a most unlikely
form an unmarked cassette tape still
inside the player when they arrived the
recording on this cassette tape came to
be known as
scp-407 it may be unassuming when
compared to immortal misanthropic lizard
monsters and multi-dimensional chaos
gods but the tape in that room if it
ever fell into the wrong hands could
cause a mass ecological catastrophe that
would inevitably bloom into a dreaded xk
class end of the world scenario so first
things first what is actually on this
tape thanks to brief samples heard and
tests with d-class personnel the
foundation was able to discover that it
was an approximately 28 minute long
recording of a song it's performed in an
unknown language and appears to be sung
a cappella style by a group of unknown
individuals fearing potential
degradation of the cassette the
foundation backed it up as an audio file
in the site 19 computer database those
who've been able to listen to the song
during testing have had an
overwhelmingly positive emotional
response describing it as soothing
glorious and beautiful
and for the first minute of its run time
the song's anomalous effect really live
up to this reputation when the song is
played it massively accelerates cell
growth within its auditory range its
potency is increased by the volume and
the length it's allowed to play it's
important to note that plugging or
covering your ears won't make any
difference the area of effect seems to
be defined by how far the sound
vibrations travel and whether you're
actually able to hear it is irrelevant
but if you're only listening for a
minute or less you'll be glad to feel
the anomalous effect of being within
scp-407's auditory range during this
specific period of time it's been shown
to be a kind of miracle cure to almost
all physical maladies with the exception
of cancer thanks to the cell growing and
rejuvenating properties of the song the
foundation discovered that 407 was an
effective treatment for alzheimer's
disease crohn's disease brain and spinal
cord injuries and normally fatal
infections or wounds amongst other
maladies it was like a version of
scp-500
the pills that can cure everything but
one that would never run out so if it's
such an effective healer why wasn't it
more widely employed by the foundation
because of what happens if you keep
listening if the song was played for two
to three minutes the subject would begin
to experience unnecessary and unchecked
cell growth particularly on the skin the
result would mostly be benign tumors and
calcium and fat deposits which though
sometimes painful and disfiguring are
not life-threatening at minute four
single-celled organisms in the auditory
vicinity of the song begin to experience
accelerated mitosis also known as cell
division this results in bacterial and
fungal growth that become extremely
dangerous for anyone and anything
exposed and beyond minute five
things become truly monstrous the
foundation only ever conducted two tests
when the song was fully played these
tests presented such a huge danger that
further testing of 407 was forbidden
without explicit permission from a
member of o5 command the first test
involved a female member of d-class
personnel in a sound-proofed but
unsterilized testing chamber as expected
she was initially delighted by the music
it cured her injured knee and brought
her back to a state of peak physical
fitness but this didn't last for long
she soon began to report intense
dizziness and stomach pain resulting in
severe sickness at this point anomalous
plant growth began in the corners of the
testing chamber it seemed as though a
whole ecosystem was coming to life and
evolving at an impossibly fast rate in
the chamber over the next few minutes
the d-class experienced a nightmarish
physical transformation her skin became
a thick calloused mass she soon devolved
further into a thick immobile blob of
pure flesh
unrecognizable as anything human while
the chamber around her was becoming a
lush rainforest of alien plants these
plants grew around and eventually on her
until there was nothing left shortly
after all the plants died and decomposed
giving away to a huge mound of anomalous
mold devouring the resulting mulch the
mold itself began to evolve growing
large mouth and hand-like structures
that it used to feed itself on the
surrounding flora and fauna as it began
to grow back when the song ended the
foundation brought the test to a close
sterilized the room and collected some
samples for later there was nothing left
of the original d-class subject the
second test wasn't any nicer while at
first the subject this time a male
member of d-class personnel appeared to
become more youthful and even gain an
inch of height as the minutes passed he
began to experience extreme discomfort
he soon began to vomit with the vomit
quickly blooming into plants plant
shoots also began to quickly spring out
of his eyes and mouth until his entire
body was destroyed by what appeared to
be a banana tree suddenly growing out of
it once again the testing chamber became
a whole ecosystem this one filled with
unique never-before-seen mammals however
it all came to an end when the room was
taken over by a fast-growing parasitic
fungus that consumed everything else
with its spores and fungal stocks and it
looked like it was breathing there was
something concerning about both of these
tests beyond the obvious physical horror
of watching death by unchecked cell
growth what was this mysterious fungus
that kept appearing and seemed to take
over everything it touched in the end
the foundation tested the samples it
collected rigorously and it came to a
surprising conclusion they'd actually
encountered this same fungus before but
not in this dimension
scp-507 is a man with dimension hopping
abilities the one problem is he can't
control where and when he hops as a
result he's been stuck in a number of
scary alternate dimensions but one
seemed eerily similar to what the
foundation was encountering with
scp-407 in one dimension he briefly
hopped into 507 encountered an abandoned
version of site 19 strewn with corpses
covered in that same breathing mold he
was horrified but decided to inspect
further hoping to find his way out of
the facility and discover some answers
about what happened here however when he
found his way out what he discovered
didn't comfort him the entire world
seemed to be covered by the same mold
there was nothing left it consumed
everything thanks to foundation tests
both molds were found to be similar to
the cordyceps fungi a kind of dangerous
parasitic mold except this one appeared
to be a far more evolved and even more
deadly version of the fungus what could
this mean what was the origin of this
anomalous song would it and the fungus
it seems to inspire someday destroy the
world as we know it and kill us all
we'll never actually know the answer to
any of this and it's thanks to an
extremely unlikely ally a person of
interest nicknamed ls
a prominent member of the serpent's hand
this enigmatic figure had previously
come into possession of scp-268
a hat that made them almost impossible
to detect with the help of this hat ls
breached site-19 in an incident that was
later dubbed security breach incident
x-23 wallets believed that ls mainly
broke into the facility to make the use
of scp-914
they performed a curious action along
the way they hacked into the foundation
database and deleted all traces of
scp-407
effectively neutralizing it in a note
left by ls they said you'll thank me for
deleting what you call 407 why would a
member of the serpent's hand a group of
interests that is often militant in
their anti-neutralization stance
neutralize an scp themselves the answer
to this lays in who exactly ls is this
mysterious figure isn't technically one
person they're a group of the same
person namely a woman named alison chao
from a number of different dimensions
they meet in the wanderers library the
headquarters of the serpent's hand that
exists between dimensions to coordinate
their missions
why does this matter in regards to
scp-407
because the nature of ls allows them to
know what's going on in a huge number of
dimensions at once this means much like
the brief glimpse given by scp-507
ls likely knows about another universe
where 407 and its horrific mold have
already caused an xk-class scenario and
destroyed the world and if it happened
there due to poor biological containment
measures or 407 falling into the wrong
hands it could happen here too
unless of course someone stepped in and
dealt with the problem personally and
while the foundation's policy is
typically to contain rather than
neutralize the anomalies they find we
have to admit we're probably with the
serpent's hand on this one some songs as
it turns out are just better left
unplayed now go watch scp-073-076
kane vs abel and scp-5031
yet another murder monster to absorb
even more knowledge about the beings
contained by the scp foundation